Kim Kardashian and Kanye West just had a
hot and heavy totally relatable date at
KFC like Kentucky Fried Chicken KFC you
guys know I eat clam face now yeah so it
seems like Kim is off that plant-based
diet because the 39 year old llama for
jetted off to Paris with her hubby
recently and shared some videos from the
City of Light that's Kim and Kanye
putting in their order at a KFC kiosk
because nothing says I'm in Paris France
like Kentucky Fried Chicken right anyway
later Kim shared this pic of Kanye deep
in that bucket of chicken while shopping
as John Paul Gaultier greasy food and
Couture I don't hate it
and neither does Kim okay so I'm totally
here for this casual date night but Kim
kept it glam and on-brand by rocking a
serious look like we're talking a
skin-tight multicolored dress and tiny
shades Bobby and the date night didn't
stop there people
Kim and Kanye steamed things up in a
Parisian elevator and naturally there's
video to prove it Kim posted this clip
to her insta story that's the reality
star and her man smooching it up in an
all glass elevator
Lala one thing is for sure these two
know how to keep the romance alive and
well the couple recently returned from a
private tropical vacay
Kim shared these pics on Instagram
giving Kanye photo cred in the caption
and writing Valentine's Day surprise
getaway remember last year when Kanye
surprised Kim with Kenny G for
Valentine's Day oh man that was great
and when et sat down with Kim in October
she dished on renewing her vows with
Kanye do your vows yes I think it's the
most beautiful thing to do so what
brought yours I thought it was just the
five year mark after being done having
all of our kids and wanting to have that
memory with our children there because I
know North was on our wedding but all of
our other kids obviously weren't even
born yet so it was really special to
have all of our kids there and have that
moment did the vows change yeah well we
had really traditional vows our first
time around and so we wrote something
that was just more intimate and special
to us and where we're at now five years
later so it definitely is different how
cute is that of course you can count on
et to bring you all the latest on these
two and all the Kardashians so make sure
to keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Holly Stephens I'll see you
soon
you